pour la grande majorité des canadiens le
jour du vote commence avec ceux ci
la carte d'information de l'électeur
envoyé par la poste d'un côté votre nom
et votre adresse
mais dans certains cas l'information
pourrait être inexactes
or cela signifie que vous n'êtes
peut-être pas sur la liste électorale
pas de panique c'est facile de corriger
la situation
accédez au site internet d'élections
canada avant la date limite ou
inscrivez-vous à votre bureau de vote le
jour du scrutin
vous trouverez à l'endos de la carte
d'électeur l'adresse de votre bureau de
vote
mais cette information n'est pas non
plus toujours exact
si tel est le cas ou si vous avez un
doute retourner sur internet
vous n'avez qu'à taper votre code postal
et voilà toute l'information devrait y
être la prochaine étape c'est d'aller
voter
la carte de l'électeur permet de
connaître l'adresse du bureau de vote
mais depuis que la loi a changé l'an
dernier cette carte n'est plus considéré
comme une pièce d'identité valide
vous avez donc besoin d'une pièce
d'identité émise par un gouvernement
avec nom adresse et photos ou encore
d'une pièce d'identité avec noms et
photos et d'un autre document d'une
institution officielle avec nom et
adresse
voilà vous êtes maintenant prêt à faire
votre devoir de citoyen qui est allé
voter